leute ich wurde von der wirtschafts
werkstatt gefragt ob ich eventuell ein
video zu dem thema schule und was danach
also was passiert danach machen könnte
da habe ich mir gedacht das mache ich
einfach mal
und falls solche frage was die
wirtschaftswelt über auf ist ein link
dazu ist und in der video beschreibung
etwas perplex willkommen bei einem ein
video und zwar ist mir aufgefallen es
gibt das ein thema das gibt's auf
youtube eigentlich kaum beziehungsweise
noch gar nicht aber das sollte
eigentlich so speziell auch für euch
ziemlich wichtig sein und zwar ihr geht
jetzt zur schule aber danach kommt
natürlich noch viel mehr und darauf wird
man eher wenig vorbereitet und ich habe
einfach mal wird man euch darüber zu
sprechen und deswegen macht man das auch
heute also ist ein bisschen was anderes
aber ich wünsche euch viel spaß und ich
rate euch natürlich auch dran zu bleiben
also mir ist vor allem jetzt in meiner
schullaufbahn aufgefallen man wird in
der schule eigentlich kaum
beziehungsweise gar nicht darauf
vorbereitet wie es eigentlich so nach
dem abi oder nach dem abschluss halt
weiter geht wie man mit geld umgeht
welche versicherungen abschließen sollte
und so was halt alles das spielt der
schule halt irgendwie kaum eine rolle
und an stattdessen gibt's dann oftmals
themen die für einen selber total
uninteressant sind und die braucht man
generell auch gar nicht so für seine
zukunft ich wette da könnt ihr alle
sollen liedchen von sinkt aber ich bin
lasse dir selbst mal dabei die schuld
versuchen sicher vieles einen jetzt
bestmöglich auf das leben vorzubereiten
aber jeder schüler hat halt andere
interessen und das ist schon sehr schwer
also eher nicht wirklich umsetzbar ich
wollte ihr kennt das auch alles oder ihr
lernt ist noch kennen und zwar sind dass
irgendwelche veranstaltung wo ist da
noch irgendwelche berufsfelder gehen die
euch eigentlich gar nicht interessieren
oder die halt einfach nur weil sie nicht
total unnötig sind deswegen ist es
wirklich sehr sehr wichtig sich wirklich
frühzeitig gedanken zu machen in welche
richtung man gehen will und dann
sicherheit auch frühzeitig zu bewerben
weil meistens ist dann halt schon zu
spät das ist halt so da ich jetzt auch
noch selber schüler bin ich kann halt
nicht so aus meiner erfahrung sprechen
was sie aber für mich heraus gefunden
habe es ist wirklich sehr wichtig dass
ihr euch selber dafür interessiert und
euch dann auch selber informiert was für
euch jetzt in frage kommt und das jetzt
nicht einfach so auf eure schule und
schiebt oder so weil das wird nichts
wenn ihr dann euren schulabschluss
gemacht habe ist natürlich an erst- oder
sag mal so dann spielt ja eigentlich so
gelten ziemlich große rolle ich meine
ihr macht das ja eigentlich alles nur um
geld zu verdienen um zu überleben und so
weiter halten gut klarzukommen sowas als
ihr wisst was ich meine und dann muss
man sich natürlich auch darüber im
klaren sein wie viel geld man wirklich
benötigt und ob mal auch so auf
unterstützung der eltern hoffen kann
wenn ihr also eher nette eltern habt ihr
auch wirklich finanziell gut dastehen
sollte das eigentlich kein problem sein
aber man muss ja auch mit dem anderen
fall ausgehen und ja wenn man halt einen
studio für euch in frage kommt muss man
das ja irgendwie finanzieren können ein
weg der dafür infrage kommt also so was
das finanzielle angeht ja aber auch mal
zeit und anstrengung in anspruch
entfernen stipendium ich erklären was
das ist also ein stipendiums einfach
eine art talentförderung sage ich mal
und zwar wenn jetzt zum beispiel im
bereich tanzen wirklich gut sein und
dort auch euer studio machen wollt dann
kann es sein dass zum beispiel so eine
art tanz akademie oder sag ich mal
objekt aufmerksam wird und euch halt so
einen bestimmten betrag pro monat dazu
gibt damit jetzt ganz einfach besser
meistern könnte es wirklich eine gute
sache
mal angenommen das geld wieder halt
nicht reichen dann müsst ihr euch
natürlich um noch mehr sachen kümmern
wie zum beispiel im nebenjob denn nehmen
dann auch wieder zeit in anspruch wohl
nicht lernen können und so was alles
nicht das ist ja schon ziemlich viel ja
und wie jetzt gerade mitbekommen das
sind wirklich sehr sehr viele dinge die
da eine große rolle spielen und nach
meinem schulabschluss ich will jetzt
nicht sagen ich hab angst aber ich habe
sehr großen respekt davor wie es
weitergeht und dass man sich dann
nämlich ins zeug legen muss weil sonst
die zahl schlecht aussah und ich hatte
ja schon am anfang gesagt falls ihr euch
wirklich weiterhin informieren wollt was
insbesondere die finanzielle zukunft
nach der schule angeht dann schon auf
jeden fall und in der video beschreibung
vorbei dort ist aline zu wirtschafts
werkstatt wirklich eine sehr informative
seite
deswegen checker smart ja das weiß
natürlich mal etwas ernsteres video mal
was anderes ich würde sagen haltet euch
dennoch gefallen hat und das jetzt nicht
zu viele informationen auf einmal waren
das auf jeden fall noch um da würde mich
sehr freuen
ansonsten jetzt hier oben weiter mit
meinem letzten lasst euch überraschen
oder so und ich würde sagen hatte